[Musique]
via les antennes d'accord mais
ou à la montagne eh bien depuis neuf ans
il ya des jeunes qui viennent à orléans
pour une colonie de mathématiques
ça s'appelle le centre gallois et c'est
unique en france
ça s'adresse à des jeunes à la fin de
leur classe de seconde qui viennent
pendant une semaine en immersion
complète avec des chercheurs de
mathématiques alors vous vous demandez
peut-être
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pour être
punis comme ça ne va pas du tout ils
viennent de leur plein gré ils et elles
passent une semaine extrêmement
intéressante et à la fin de la semaine
ils repartent avec plein de belles idées
mathématiques et des regrets que ça soit
déjà fini
alors vous avez sans doute entendu
encore récemment que les mathématiques
ça fait peur je peux vous assurer que
depuis neuf ans au centre gallois ça
fait pas peur à tous les jeunes
je vais vous raconter la genèse du
centre gallois c'était donc il ya dix
ans je suis directeur du laboratoire de
mathématiques de l'université d'orléans
alors on a l'habitude de recevoir des
élèves de 3e pour un stage un jour je
reçois un appel d'une famille car leur
fille claire marie voudrais faire un
stage dans un laboratoire de
mathématiques et eux ils voient pas trop
ce que c'est un laboratoire de maths et
donc avant de laisser leur fille passer
une semaine dans un endroit aussi
d'étranges ils veulent me rencontrer je
les ai reçus et j'ai compris que claire
marie elle avait dû être
particulièrement motivé et convaincante
pour emmener ses parents dans un
laboratoire de l'université
enfin bref le stage s'est fait c'était
super et avec un collègue philippe
grillot on s'est dit que devait y avoir
en fait plein d'enfants dans la région
qui eux avaient envie de mathématiques
et un an après le centre gallois a été
créé et en fait c'est pour partager
cette passion pour les mathématiques que
je suis ici aujourd'hui avec vous alors
j'en vois qui sont plongées sur leur
téléphone peut-être que vous cherchez
des informations sur le centre gallois
alors gallois a rien à voir avec le pays
de galles ni avec france gall je vais
vous aider
ça s'écrit avec un seul l oui c'est le
nom du célèbre mathématicien evariste
galois evariste galois un héros mythique
des mathématiques du 19e siècle
et ça pour plusieurs raisons
premièrement il est mort très jeune a 20
ans des suites d'un duel galant ensuite
ils étaient engagés politiquement ça
arrive parfois à des mathématiciens
français les plus brillants et puis
surtout il a apporté des nouvelles idées
très puissante et profonde pour les
mathématiques qu'on appelle la théorie
de galois
la théorie de galois elle a était pas
facile à comprendre d'ailleurs le
l'article de gallois le plus important
il a été publié 14 ans après sa mort
grâce à joseph youville il l'avait
envoyé aux grands savants denis poisson
qui avait pas vraiment compris l'intérêt
la puissance de ses idées bon pour la
défense de denis poissons les idées de
gallois était vraiment révolutionnaire
il était anarchiste et et puis bon
c'était pas très bien rédigé enfin bon
voilà maintenant vous connaissez un
petit peu evariste galois et ça me fait
vraiment très plaisir
parce que comme on dit en mathématiques
nul n'est censé ignorer gallois
alors alors la théorie de galois elle a
permis des avancées extrêmement
importante en mathématiques par exemple
elle a permis de démontrer le dernier
théorème de fermat fermat avait énoncé
ce théorème il y a plus de 300 ans est
paraît-il il n'avait pas la place dans
la marge pour écrire la démonstration et
et c'est un des problèmes les plus
célèbres une énigme qui a résisté
pendant 300 ans aux efforts des
mathématiciens et qui a été démontré il
ya 25 ans grâce à andrew wiles et la
théorie de galois
et alors je vais vous raconter un petit
peu ce que moi je fais dans mes séances
au centre gallois donc pendant deux
heures je parle aux enfants de seconde
de nombreux binaire et de la base 2 du
codage et c'est en fait je parle du lien
naturel entre les mathématiques et
l'informatique
alors en informatique on sait bien que
c'est des 0 et des 1 01 base 2 est bien
en mathématiques c'est la même chose en
fait en mathématiques une proposition
mathématiques elle ne peut être que
vraies ou fausses
il n'y a pas de troisième voie c'est ce
qu'on appelle ça un principe fondamental
de la logique qu'on appelle le principe
du tiers exclu et c'est extrêmement
important parce qu'une fois que quelque
chose est vraie ou qu'il est faux comme
0 et 1
et bien c'est vrai pour l'éternité plus
plus longtemps que la durée de vie d'une
tablette en marbre dans lequel on
pourrait graver ce résultat alors un
pour montrer que quelque chose est vraie
on utilise une démonstration une preuve
et pour montrer que le résultat est faux
on utilise par exemple des contre
exemples
alors ça veut pas dire que les choses
sont simples il ya plein de résultats
dont on sait pas encore s'ils sont dans
la catégorie
vrai ou faux par exemple théorème de
fermat il est resté dans le statut qu'on
appelle de conjectures pendant 300 ans
jusqu'à la démonstration par andrew
house et 25 ans mais donc le travail du
mathématicien
c'est de démêler le vrai du faux d'une
certaine façon
matheu ces chasseurs de fait qu news
alors je vous ai dit que le centre
gallois il était unique en france
mais il ya d'autres expériences dans le
monde et cet été j'ai rencontré aline
estime qu' à un collègue turc qui a qui
venait de recevoir le prix les hlavaty
le prix mondial de popularisation des
mathématiques il avait créé le village
mathématiques près d'izmir en turquie
c'est un projet incroyable
il l'a fait sans autorisation
il ya eu des procès même de la prison
pour certaines personnes il l'a fait
sans budget
alors faisons appel à des dons et c'est
un succès phénoménal l'an dernier il ya
quatorze mille enfants turcs qui ont
participé au village mathématiques 14000
pour découvrir l'esprit mathématique et
comprendre comprendre qu'ils pouvaient
avoir confiance dans leurs capacités de
raisonnement alors avec ali on s'est
rendu compte qu'on avait des souvenirs
communs il ya des gens qui savent ce qui
faisait le 11 septembre 2001 bien avec
ali on s'est rappelé du 23 juin 1993 le
23 juin 1993
et oui c'est ce jour-là que le théorème
de fermat avaient été démontrés ali
était à londres moi j'étais à paris on
se connaissait pas du tout mais en fait
tous les deux on était très heureux et
hyper fier d'être mathématicien et de
faire partie d'une communauté la
communauté mathématique qui venait de
remporter une victoire contre
l'ignorance de faire avancer la
connaissance pour toute l'humanité
alors revenons en france la france est
un pays assez particulier pour les
mathématiques
parce que c'est un pays qui est mal
classé pour l'enseignement avec les
classements pisa par exemple
et pour la recherche on est
particulièrement bien classés par
exemple avec les médaillés fixes qui
sont attribués tous les quatre ans à des
mathématiciens de moins de 40 ans le
deuxième pays au monde derrière les
états unis mais lorsqu'on sait beaucoup
moins c'est que quand on demande aux
collégiens aux jeunes
quelle est leur discipline préférée est
bien la discipline préférée des
collégiens après le sport c'est les
mathématiques alors moi quand j'étais
quand j'étais au collège je savais pas
qu'on pouvait faire de la recherche en
mathématiques est d'ailleurs j'aurais
pensé plutôt faire de l'architecturé
mais quelques années après un prof m'a
expliqué que en faisant des
mathématiques ça me permettrait de
travailler dans des domaines très divers
et je le lait cru et ça fait 25 ans que
je fais des mathématiques
eh bien je ne regrette pas du tout je
regrette pas du tout parce que ça m'a
permis de travailler à dans des domaines
extrêmement variés
j'ai travaillé avec des physiciens des
plasmas spatiaux qui s'intéresse aux
aurores boréales
j'ai travaillé avec des économistes qui
s'intéressent à la répartition des
richesses et des collègues italiens
j'ai travaillé avec des astrophysiciens
qui s'intéressent au trou noir avec des
spécialistes des matériaux qui
s'intéresse aux milieux granulaires j'ai
aussi travaillé avec des experts en
neurosciences qui s'intéresse au
processus de décision et des collègues
espagnols qui sont maintenant en
angleterre et tout ça avec mon sujet de
recherche mathématique les équations aux
dérivées partielles non linéaire
hyperbolique
désolé bref
bref les mathématiques ça permet c'est
un langage universel qui permet de
travailler dans pleins pleins de
domaines et actuellement mon sujet
principal c'est sur l'hydrologie avec
mon équipe mon travail pour développer
des algorithmes et des méthodes
mathématiques pour calculer les
solutions de l'écoulement d'eau par
exemple pour des problèmes d'inondations
les problèmes de tsunami ou bien des
problèmes liés à l'écoulement dans les
canalisations en milieu urbain et cette
équation qui ont été proposées par
adhémar barré de saint venant
il ya plus de 150 ans et on continue
régulièrement de faire est d'améliorer
les méthodes pour les rendre plus
précises plus rapide pour que mieux
prédire les inondations comprendre
l'effet de l'urbanisation par exemple
est actuellement là on a un projet qui
commence avec la chine pour comprendre
le phénomène de sédimentation dans les
canalisations
donc l'idée c'est d'essayer de prédire
où et quand un tuyau va se bouger de
façon à pouvoir intervenir avant ça
s'appelle la maintenance prédictive
vous voyez c'est quand même très concret
un bon si vous avez des canalisations
doucher chez vous appelez plutôt un
plombier a quand même
alors depuis quelques années en fait je
me suis aussi intéressé beaucoup aux
relations entre les mathématiques et les
entreprises à travers l' agence matt
entreprises
agnès et ça m'a permis de prendre
conscience de l'intérêt économique pour
les entreprises d'utiliser les
meilleures méthodes mathématiques mais
aussi l'intérêt scientifique pour les
mathématiciens de s'intéresser à des
problèmes proposées par les entreprises
et en fait on pourrait faire beaucoup
mieux beaucoup plus pour ça il faudrait
être plus nombreux il faudrait qu'ils
aient plus de jeunes qui s'intéressent
aux études mathématiques ou scientifique
en général est que plus de gens se forme
tout au long de la vie pour profiter des
opportunités qui sont liées à la
révolution numérique au big data
intelligence artificielle les objets
côté etc et à orléans on a créé un
projet l'année dernière qui s'appelle
icône institut convergence orléans
numérique icône tout un proto un symbole
le projet icône rassemble les étudiants
les chercheurs les entreprises qui
s'intéressent au numérique
et pour vous donner juste un seul
chiffre la lettre de d'information qui
s'applique aux news à plus de 1800
abonné peut peut-être même quelques-uns
dans la salle on a aussi on a aussi créé
une formation qui s'appelle la graduate
school orléans numérique qui permet aux
étudiants de l'université d'orléans en
master ou en doctorat de se former pour
devenir data scientist mais en fait il
ya énormément de possibilités de moyens
de se former et rien qu'à orléans en
2018 il ya eu une centaine d'événements
au labo ou sur le campus de l'université
il ya des livres il ya des vidéos des
cours en ligne
il ya énormément de possibilités pour se
former aux mathématiques en fait
apprendre comprendre ou découvrir les
mathématiques c'est un petit peu comme
participer à la construction de
barricades contre l'ignorance dans le
cadre de la révolution numérique en
étant du côté de la science et de la
vérité et je suis persuadé que parmi les
enfants qui viennent au centre gallois
ou au village mathématiques en turquie
se trouvent les gavroches de cette
révolution les mathématiques
elles sont partout mais on les voit pas
elles sont vitales mais elles sont
invisibles
en fait les mathématiques c'est
l'oxygène du monde numérique
alors la prochaine fois que votre
smartphone vous donnera une information
utile penser que vous venez de recevoir
une belle bouffée de mathématiques
merci
[Applaudissements]